hey this is preshtalwalkar
a semi-circle contains an inscribed
semi-circle whose arc is tangent to the
diameter of the large semi-circle
dividing it into distances of two and
one
if the inscribed semi-circle has a
diameter whose length is equal to y
solve for the value of y
that's part one of the question
part two is to
generalize suppose the large
semicircle's diameter is divided into
lengths of a and b
solve for y in terms of a and b
part 3
label the center of the large semicircle
as o and the center of the inscribed
semicircle as p
consider all such inscribed semi-circles
and their center point p
the question is what is the locus of p
that is what is the set of points that
describes all possible positions of p
i thank nick from greece for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's solve for the general case first
let t be the point of tangency along the
large semicircle's diameter and let q be
this upper point of tangency
since the inscribed semicircle has a
diameter equal to y its radius will be
equal to y over 2. construct the radius
p t
because t is a point of tangency
p t will be perpendicular to the
diameter of the large semicircle
furthermore it's a radius of the
inscribed semicircle so its length will
be equal to y over 2.
now construct oq
it's a radius of the large semicircle
the large semicircle has a diameter
equal to a plus b
so its radius will be half of a plus b
next construct the distance ot
its distance will be equal to the radius
of the large semicircle minus b we can
substitute for the radius of the large
semicircle and then we can simplify
ot will be equal to a minus b all over
2.
now construct the radius that goes
through the points o and p
because this bisects the diameter of the
inscribed semicircle
it will be the perpendicular bisector
we now have two different right
triangles that we can focus on
let's get rid of everything else
we will now calculate the length op
squared in two different ways
first let's calculate it in the blue
triangle
it will be equal to the quantity a minus
b all over 2 squared plus y over 2 the
quantity squared
now in the green triangle we can
calculate op squared in a different way
it will be equal to the square of the
hypotenuse of this triangle
minus the square of one of its legs so
this will be the quantity a plus b over
two squared
minus y over two the quantity squared
we have two equations that are equal to
op squared so we can set these two
equations equal to each other
let's do that
we will now simplify by squaring each
term
now each term has a denominator equal to
4
so these will cancel out
we will now group like terms
we will then simplify this equation the
left-hand side is 2y squared and the
right-hand side will expand each
binomial
we can then cancel out a squared and b
squared
so we're left with 2y squared is equal
to 4ab
we divide both sides by 2 and then we
simplify
thus y squared is equal to 2 a b
so we solve part 2 of the problem we
have y as a function of a and b
if we want it to be more explicit we
could say y is equal to the positive
square root of 2 a b
now let's tackle part 1.
we have the two distances of a is equal
to 2 and b is equal to 1.
so we substitute y squared is equal to
two times two times one
this means y squared is equal to four
and y is equal to two
that's part one of the question
let's now tackle part
consider the triangle otp
we know that pt is equal to y over 2.
without loss of generality suppose the
large semicircle has a radius equal to
1.
suppose that ot has a length equal to x
then the remaining distance will be
equal to 1 minus x
from our formula that y squared is equal
to 2 times a times b
we can see that a here is equal to 1
plus x and b is equal to 1 minus x so we
have y squared is equal to 2 multiplied
by the quantity 1 plus x multiplied by
the quantity 1 minus x
we can simplify this y squared is equal
to two minus two x squared
now we're interested in the locus of
point p
the point p has coordinates of x comma y
over two
so let's go back and simplify our
equation further
we can rewrite it as 2x squared plus y
squared is equal to 2
then dividing both sides by 2 we get x
squared plus y squared over 2 is equal
to 1.
we can further rewrite this as x squared
plus 2 multiplied by the quantity y over
2 squared is equal to 1.
and from here we can see that this is
the equation of an ellipse therefore the
locus of p is a semi ellipse it'll be
the upper half of the ellipse described
by this equation
this is the analytic solution
for fun let's see it animated
as we change the inscribed semi-circle
the point p will trace out the curve of
a semi-ellipse
this is a beautiful geometry problem and
i hope you had as much fun solving it as
i did
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of bind your decisions or we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you